(wind blowing)
(solemn music)
(engine humming)
When you work with
archaeological objects,
you are like entering the
world of your ancestors.
(mysterious music)
I like to think that in
a way, they talk to us.
(mysterious music)
A Quipu is an accounting
device made of cotton strings
that used knots to
represent numbers.
(mysterious music)
A Quipu is the accountance
of life (laughs).
(mysterious music)
The Quipus were made in
Inca times by Quipucamayocs.
(mysterious music)
The Quipucamayocs, the only
ones who were able to read it,
die and didn't pass the knowledge
to the next generations.
There's a lot of questions
still to get answered.
My biggest hope for Inkawasi
is to be able to excavate
all the site.
(gentle bell music)
The Quipus are
very well preserved
because the environment
of the Peruvian coast
is very arid.
So you have a very
good preservation of
any organic remain.
(gentle bell music)
This must be 600 years old.
And as you can see the
preservation is very well.
(gentle bell music)
We know that the numbers
who found in the Quipus
are the counts of these product.
(gentle bell music)
[Woman] They have been
buried for 600 years
and so what we do
is the conservation.
That means keep them clean
and straight so the analyzer
can come and study them.
I think this discovery would
bring a better understanding
of Quipus and also in how the
Incas dominate and control
these local populations.
Many people say that
because we had no writing
our culture was not developed.
But we really have
things like Quipus that show
that it was a very
developed culture.
Every time it's exciting
because we are finding them
in different contexts and
in different situations.
And different sizes,
different shapes, colors, knots.
So we can have a very
big data of these Quipus.
So we can compare them and
get any kind of insight
to see how to read them
or how to understand them.
(gentle bell music)
The first one when you
see them like really dirty
spaghetti and then the
end they are just like
"take me a picture," they
are so pretty.(laughs)
I think the Quipus
are grateful (laughs).
(gentle upbeat music)
(paper tearing)